yann elies bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous vous vous présenter aux élections
législatives dans le centre bell
président du mouvement citoyen du de
martinique alors pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin ce n'est pas
la première fois non c'est pas première
phase est une continuité c'est le combat
que je mène depuis depuis trois ans déjà
en martinique pour redonner un peu de
sens à la politique pour me combattre
aussi ces problématiques qu'on a et
donner un peu d'eux de mieux à la
martinique d'améliorer la condition de
vie de chacun et cette extraction que je
continue mon combat et que toi en cette
année pour ces législatives il décidé de
me présenter et de défendre la première
circonscription de martinique quels sont
les deux ou trois projets prioritaires
que vous souhaitez défendre si vous êtes
élu au sein de lamartine au sein de
l'assemblée nationale pour représenter
le territoire martinique le premier
projet le plus important c'est pour
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
martiniquais au travers de l'octroi de
mer c'est une taxe sur laquelle on
battait depuis déjà deux ans on a lancé
une manifestation le 7 juillet 2021 au
niveau de la cité m
aujourd'hui le gouvernement semble
porter un intérêt à cette taxe et nous
notre proposition c'est de la supprimer
et d'apporter une compensation en
augmentant la dotation de l'état pour
permettre aux communes de pouvoir
substituer à au travers de cette taxe la
suppression de cette taxe par une
augmentation de la dotation de l'état
donc la lutte contre la vie chère qu
quelle pollution des sols c'est un
combat aussi qu'on a qu'on a mené qu'on
mène depuis
la l'élection de la ctm on avait proposé
des solutions là haut niveau maintenant
grâce à l'élection législative on va
essayer d'apporter des solutions au-delà
du territoire pour rencontrer des
personnes qui font effectivement
proposer des solutions travailler sur le
terrain et aussi permettre aux
martiniquais de pouvoir rentrer dans une
autosuffisance alimentaire parce qu'on a
de quoi faire en matinée pour permettre
aux martiniquais de se nourrir
correctement est ce qu'il y aurait un
troisième dossier un dossier qui vient
si les transports on voit aussi ça aussi
c'est un des points importants en
martinique une fois problématique là
dessus et il ya besoin de faire un
travail conséquent là dessus pour
permettre aux martiniquais des pouvoirs
librement circuler ce qui pourrait
permettre aussi à l'économie
martiniquaise de s'améliorer parce qu'on
voit bien quand on prend l'exemple de la
france que
quand on a un transport en commun qui
qui est opérationnel et fonctionnel
l'économie autour fonctionne fonctionne
bien et en martinique on a besoin de ça
pour développer encore le territoire
alors vous vous présentez sur la
circonscription du centre atlantique
quelles sont d'après vous les priorités
qu'il faudrait des formes si en tant que
député ah ben là c'est ce que je vois en
contrant les gens c'est vrai que je
parlais de transport sûr sur le centre
c'est vrai que c'est une voie
pragmatique on a vu à roubaix on a vu au
cours morts dont deux voies au lamentin
qu'il y ait de vraies difficultés pour
les personnes à pouvoir circuler sur ces
territoires là il va falloir travailler
là dessus pour permettre aux gens de
pouvoir se mouvoir librement et c'est
vrai que comme jeudi avoir un transport
en commun efficience à permettent de
d'améliorer l'économie il faut aussi que
les entreprises autour puissent pouvoir
élargir leurs heures d'ouverture pour
permettre aux martiniquais qui travaille
peut-être pendant la journée de pouvoir
aller à des vaquer à des occupations en
dehors de ces temps là donc ça c'est
vraiment important souvent sur ses toits
zone là et puis derrière ben continue à
améliorer le quotidien des martiniquais
on a trente mille femmes qui sont au
chômage en martinique ça c'est un point
important est qu'il va falloir
travailler pour comprendre pourquoi ces
femmes sont au chômage et pouvoir aussi
les aider les accompagner pour leur
permettre d'intégrer une activité
professionnelle sereinement qu'avez vous
à dire de plus aux électeurs de dire aux
électeurs qu'ils nous écoutent qui nous
regardent bien aujourd'hui c'est leur
choix c'est l'heure c'est leur action
comme je le dis toujours s'il ya eu de
prendre la main sur ce qui va se passer
là c'est leur avenir qui est en jeu et
le et puis s'engageront dans cette
démarche plus vision pour améliorer
leurs conditions et derrière dans les
années à venir la martinique pour
rayonner différemment et chacun d'entre
nous pourra bénéficier de l'action qu'il
aurait entrepris aujourd'hui yann
gewillig merci merci à vous
[Musique]